[Musica]
chi ha spostato nel formaggio no non ho
fame è il titolo di una storia scritta
da spencer johnson che racconta di due
nomi tentenna e rido lino vivono in un
labirinto e ogni giorno vanno in cerca
di formaggio ogni giorno si alzano
cercano infine dormono un po finché
finalmente ne trovano una bella scorta
una montagna di formaggio
così senza pensarci due volte si
trasferiscono gli siano la scorta
d'altra parte ormai hanno tutto quello
che desiderano una montagna di formaggio
a portata di mano e la possibilità di
restare a pancia all'aria smettono di
fare qualsiasi cosa e si godono il
meritato riposo mangiandone pezzetti
quando sono affamati non giorno il
formaggio sparisce un autentico
cataclisma tentenna non si dà pace che
ha spostato il mio formaggio dice
fissando il punto dove fino al giorno
prima c'era la loro riserva in realtà
poteva essere successo di tutto anche
che i due avessero semplicemente
terminato la scortano ma tentenna rimane
a fissare lo spazio vuoto e basta
ridolini invece dopo un po si stufa e
decide di partire il labirinto è grande
e pieno di cunicoli e biforcazione che
compaiono all'improvviso gridolino vaga
lungo e più cammina più i percorsi
sembrano moltiplicarsi come se non
dovessero terminare mai ma lui non si
scoraggia scavi
si arrampica finché davanti a lui
compare una nuova enorme scorta di
formaggio insistendo ha trovato ciò che
cercava perché vi ho raccontato questa
storia perché la storia con la s
maiuscola è costellata di tintin aeree
dolino persone pronte a lamentarsi di
continuo immobili in attesa che le cose
si risolvano in qualche modo e di altri
che si rimboccano le maniche anche a
costo di seguire percorsi sconosciuti
magari senza sapere come fare
ma mettendosi in cerca sapete cosa ha
imparato rido lino alla fine della
storia
l'unione ha imparato a essere più
attento a ciò che sa e sa come lo
consuma
ma anche a restare all'erta pronto nuove
stelle delle esplorazioni girare in una
parola cambiare e se ci pensiamo
la storia è sempre quella con la s
maiuscola è costellata di persone che
hanno un passo alla volta cambiato
qualcosa
spostato limiti creato nuovi orizzonti
il percorso di queste persone ha
attraversato le epoche con le loro
oscillazioni economiche sociali e i
tanti ridolini di ogni epoca secolo dopo
secolo ci hanno portato fin qui
continuando a migliorare che cosa le
condizioni di vita l'educazione il
mestiere le professioni la salute verso
ciò che definiamo benessere una
condizione di felicità complessiva che
può assumere significati diversi a
seconda della percezione soggettiva
in ogni caso negli ultimi decenni
il benessere è ulteriormente cresciuto
grazie soprattutto ai progressi nella
ricerca nell'educazione e nella
tecnologia e grazie all'innovazione nei
sistemi produttivi che ha avuto un
impatto evidente anche nelle aziende
riflettendosi sul loro tasso di
mortalità che non è mai stato così alto
nella storia
la vita media delle più grandi aziende
quotate parte dell'indice standard and
poor 500 negli stati uniti si è
dimezzata negli ultimi 30 anni molte
startup grandi e piccole sono stati i
principali fautori della riduzione di
questa vita media e hanno anche trovato
e ovviamente occupato nuovi spazi di
attività e lo hanno fatto con nuovi
modelli alcuni esempi il più grande
albergo presenti in 81 mila città non
possiede camere airbnb una delle più
grandi società di trasporti con 4
miliardi di corse generate lo scorso
anno non ha auto huber una delle più
grandi società media con oltre 2
miliardi di utenti attivi non possiede
contenuti facebook
queste società sono entrati in settori
dove gli operatori avevano costruito il
loro vantaggio su grandi investimenti in
infrastruttura contenuto presenza locale
capillare e li hanno travolti
eppure queste società non vi ricordano
qualcuno un certo gnomo di cui vi ha
raccontato poco fa queste aziende e
molte altre sono state guidate dalla
continua ricerca di opportunità da
soddisfare e hanno portato
cambiamento con loro filosofia cultura e
visione sono campioni del processo di
distruzione creativa teorizzato
all'inizio degli anni quaranta nessun
péter come futuro dell'economia
capitalistica
ecco come sono diventati un esempio
dell'innovazione dirompente che ci
circonda e per creare quell innovazione
10 per dirompente capace di far
scaturire qualcosa di 10 volte più
avanzato dell'esistente non si sono
limitate ad esplorare labirinto ma hanno
trovato nuovi spazi già perché dal
labirinto si può anche uscire
ce lo racconta di puck malhotra nel suo
libro intitolato io ho spostato il tuo
formaggio già johnson ha domandato che
ha spostato mio formaggio e sembra che
marotta abbia risposto in questa seconda
storia ci sono tre topolini max big e
zed
sì ma lo tra se la cavava meglio con i
nomi dicevo i tre topolini decidono di
smettere di cercare il formaggio nel
labirinto e di uscirne proprio per la
prima volta la scomparsa del formaggio
non scatti ma solo cambiamenti nel
comportamento degli abitanti del
labirinto il loro ambiente conosciuto ma
anche e soprattutto rispetto al posto
stesso il cambiamento non ha più
ostacoli nei limiti perché anche i
confini di spazio possono essere sfidati
cambiati e spostati e così ogni altra
barriera
proprio come hanno fatto gli
imprenditori più innovatore hanno
spostato confini guardato oltre
territori noti sfidato persino ciò che
si poteva vedere e toccare e cercato
continuamente nuove opportunità
ok quindi come facciamo e come fanno le
nostre imprese ad essere quei topi che
escono dal labirinto prima di tutto
analizzando e capendo a fondo i
cambiamenti tecnologici regolatori e di
mercato che possono generare spostamenti
tellurici nelle situazioni competitive
consolidate poi ascoltando i consumatori
e risolvendo i problemi che incontrano
nell'acquisto di prodotti e servizi
esistenti e individuando i bisogni
latenti non espressi ma fondamentali le
prossime necessità ricercare quest'età
dimensioni porta nuova opportunità che
come per i protagonisti delle due storie
che vi ho raccontato non arrivano
all'improvviso richiedono spirito di
servizio dedizione responsabilità e
capacità di valorizzare i gruppi di
lavoro
tuttavia per scoprire nuove opportunità
possiamo prestare attenzione a tre
elementi il denaro per cominciare
seguirne le tracce aiuta a cogliere
opportunità concrete
vediamo ad esempio che ogni cinque anni
il numero di start up finanziate negli
stati uniti si è raddoppiato
e i finanziamenti hanno premiato alcune
aree di attività ha potenziale più alto
visto nella sua evoluzione da
indicazione di potenziale di rilevanza e
possibilità di attrarre capitali
poi le tecnologie quanti riescono
davvero a vedere oltre a sentire ciò che
arriverà connessioni mobili i
dispositivi indossabili l'intelligenza
artificiale la robotica la block chain
monitorare le tecnologie e le loro
applicazioni
considerando le anche dal punto di vista
umanistico e sempre strumentali
all'individuo ci può fornire utili
indicazioni
assieme ad un altro aspetto centrale
avere un incessante volontà di osservare
e di mettersi al servizio già al
servizio di pie delle persone del
consumatore di coloro che sono la
ragione di ogni attività d'impresa
ma una volta scoperte questa opportunità
siamo capaci di cogliere
ognuno di noi ha paura vincoli che ci
spingono a proteggere ogni più piccolo
spazio guadagnato spesso ricordiamo
quanta fatica e sacrifici ci è costato
se però riusciamo a mettere questi
vincoli da parte che non vuol dire
dimenticarcene badate bene ma riporli
dove dovrebbero stare accanto a noi non
davanti non con ostacoli piuttosto come
compagni di viaggio ecco che ognuno di
noi può essere il protagonista di una
storia di cambiamento e innovazione e
questa nuova storia sarà tanto più
grande quanto più grande e l'ambizione
la voglia di rischiare di scovare nuovi
orizzonti e di generare impatto di
imparare spostare limiti di uscire dal
nostro personalissimo labirinto e
perderci nel mondo in tutto il mondo
perché ciò che crediamo di sapere di noi
delle cose di tutto non è che l'inizio
di un percorso in continua evoluzione
che ne dite restiamo fermi ad aspettare
ora
abbracciare il cambiamento
riappropriarsene è la base per una vita
migliore per una società migliore quella
in cui io vorrei vivere grazie
[Applauso]